I want to mention something's being good
shows recently I visited South Korea and
yeah and we put together we put together
a special show about South Korea all
about my travels there and my adventures
I'm really proud of it I think it's a
really good show it's airing this
Saturday April 9th at 11 p.m.
that's right this Saturday we don't
usually air on Saturdays but this
Saturday April 9th 11 p.m. here's just a
quick taste
finally a country that gets me yeah
while we were in Korea while in Korea
this is kind of cool the walking dead
Steven Yeun and I recorded a song with
kpop legend jy Park called fire this is
all real the song features kpop
sensations Wonder Girls and twice we
also spent 16 hours filming the kpop
music video for fire and that's going to
be yes now get this both the song and
the video will drop this Saturday at
midnight during our show
while it's simultaneously released in
Korea where it will no doubt climb to
the top of the charts making me an
international kpop superstar
before that happen I'm quoting in Korea
this Saturday at 11 p.m. so check that
out
you